hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the new york rice
tournament of 1916 it's a game between
Jacob Karl Rosenthal and Jose rule
Capablanca again I'm forced to use a
photo of the hoodie guy was unable to
find the photo but which is quite odd as
the mr. Rosenthal was the champion of
the Manhattan chess club in 1911 and in
New York state champion in 1912 and he's
he is a quite a strong player he did
quite well in this tournament but now he
faces the Cuban legend Jose rule
capablanca who is so far eighteen eight
so eight wins in a row this is around
nine let's see how mr. Rosenthal does
against capablanca it's it's a wonderful
game I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it so
let's just dive straight into it
Rosenthal opens the game with d4 we have
d5 Knight to f3 Knight to f6 c4 and e6
we entered the Queens gambit declined
Knight to c3 by Rosenthal Knight bt7 by
Capablanca and III and here Bishop to b6
you could also go for Bishop e7 but
Bishop to d6 is a bit more active move
but it does invite white to grab more
space with c5 which rosenthal does with
c5 mushroom now has to go back with
Bishop to e7 and now before just
creative creating a massive pawn chain
on the Queen side we have c6 and now
comes a three so the pawn chain is very
nicely yeah cemented there we have Queen
to c7 by Capablanca the knight and queen
and now control the e5 square and couple
blanca hopes well if you can get this
ePHI move in the game early on that he
shouldn't have problems equalizing this
game Bishop to b2 by white we have
castles by kappa blanka
and now Bishop to d3 White is now ready
to castle but as white they didn't
really do anything to prevent Capablanca
from pushing e5 capablanca now does it
with E 5 and it's a nice principled move
the White King gets low in the center if
you can push if I'll get rid of your
backwards pawn you should always do it
the threat of course II for winning the
piece of white must react to this pawn
push the characters on e5 with Knight
captures on e5 Knight captures Queen
captures and there are no useful
discoveries you can't really do anything
Knight b5 Queen just goes back so it
doesn't really it doesn't really do
anything
so here Queen to c2 putting pressure on
the age seven pawn and Capablanca now
moves the Queen so no nasty discoveries
will be possible in the future Queen to
h5 Queen g5 is interesting going after
the G to pawn but it doesn't really do
anything white can just give up the g2
pawn and you will not be able to grab it
if you grab it then do you see how white
takes advantage of this not look the g1
right away but first the bishop captures
on h7 this is the problem now white
can't capture it black can capture
because if black captures only now roof
to g1 as now the bishop and rook are
nicely connected towards the g7 pawn and
here black must part with the Queen if
you don't if you play Queen h3 then it's
a well it's a very standard mating idea
it's a forced mate in seven but you know
if you're interested in learning it as
you will often see it in your own games
I imagine I feel free to pause the video
and try to find this force meeting
sequence I'll give you a couple of
seconds if you're if you're interested
in trying further we were able to do it
from graduations you were an excellent
major in seven and for those who just
wanna enjoy the show of course the first
move is roof to g7 but now you you have
to think of the windmills King to h8 and
now first rook captures on h7 delivering
check with the bishop and also with the
rook and the Queen is protecting the
rook so the King has to move it's the
only move and now you don't capture the
Queen you're not interested in that
you're going for checkmate back row g7
you force the King back to the h8 square
and now rook captures on f7 check
freeing the g6 square for the white
queen and now you don't really have any
good moves you have to block then Bishop
captures you have to block again Bishop
captures and finally after the King
moves now the g6 square is free for the
white queen and here the Queen delivers
checkmate so a very nice checkmate but
it's a very nice sequence that never
actually happened because capablanca
went to Queen to h5 Knights the e2 by
white we have Knights - I ate the night
from eight will be guarding the g7 phone
very nicely also f5 can be played if
needed and here white has to make a
choice thus you want to go for castles
and play you know a fairly safe game
or does you want to go for the queenside
castle and play an opposite side castles
game where you know it will be very
sharp because white can now start an
attack on the Kings side you don't have
to be worried about pushing the pawns in
front of your king but Capablanca will
now freely attack White's King on the
Queen side so capablanca does exactly
that he wastes no time he goes a five
who wants to bust open the pawn
structure on the Queen side and white it
doesn't waste time either
we have h4 couple Monica goes H capture
Sun before we have a cat person before
and now Bishop to f6 just opposing this
bishop as it is a very strong piece fro
from white but a white isn't interested
in trading so nice the d4 and you don't
really have any options of dislodging
this knight from d4 so for the moment
the tension remains we have Knight to c7
the knight is no longer needed as the
the dark square bishop from white isn't
really a threat towards the g7 square
anymore so now the knight can be
transferred either to e6 or b5 depending
on what white place white again doesn't
waste time Rosenthal goes for f3
prepares g4 as the bishop is not a
nicely placed on f6 g4 g5 could be a
very nice advancement and now Queen to
h6 not allowing g4 to come with the
tempo and also threatening the e3 pawn
which is a backwards pawn so now it is a
weakness the rosenthal defensive move
Queen to b2 and now looked ei putting
more pressure towards the e3 pawn we
have rook D to e 1 and now look to a to
go by kappa blanka a very nice move as
it doesn't allow the bishop to move and
also it grabs a lot of space it's a very
active look but Rosenthal doesn't allow
it to remain there first Bishop to B 1
and here an interesting move by kappa
blanka
Bishop captures on d4 and now if you
capture the rook on a2 then a couple
Blancas idea was a bunch of captures on
e3
and now if you don't want lose the Queen
you have to give the room back rook
captures rook captures and Capablanca
would have a very nice game here and
pretty much he would have stopped a
White's attack so Rosenthal doesn't
allow this he doesn't go for Bishop
captures an e2 instead he goes for
captures and sorry now the bishop
captures Queen captures on d4 which
captures will be just terrible as you
would lose the Queen and now the rope
has to move we'll look to a four and now
Bishop the c2 again forcing the rook to
move even further back
now if rope to a2 then King b1 you you
will just force it back so there's no
point in even trying kappa blanka has to
go back with the rook rook to e8 and now
Rosenthal repelled coupling has attacked
on the Queen side both of the bishops
are nicely slicing over to the Kings
side and the pawns are ready to be put
on the King side as well so without
further ado g4 we have Knights to b5
getting the knight deeper into the
position while attacking the Queen Queen
to d3 and now rook to f8 capablanca is
now ready to push f5 so he can sorry f5
so he can activate his light-square
bishop and here we have rook eat the g1
this move is a bit too slow you you you
should immediately go for hh5 g5 because
after rook eat the g1 which was played a
couple blanca just returns rook to e8
puts pressure towards the e3 pawn and
now white has them ways to move once
again so rook to e1 and now Bishop to d7
just developing a piece as there really
isn't a better way to develop it and
here white plays a really an awesome
move it's h5 preparing g5 and here kappa
blanka asked to figure out how to
prevent g5 in the game Capablanca played
f5 but this is this is not enough the
correct move is f6 you have to prevent
g5 but Capablanca played f5 as the
bishop now also guards DF v square but
this simply doesn't work so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
idea for white in this position as and
if you're interested do take your time
it's really a complicated idea which
requires a lot of thoughts so you know
if you have the time you know do do
check it out I'll give you a couple of
seconds to decide well I have a nice sip
of my water
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you've just created an
amazing attack that never actually
happened in the game in the game
Rosenthal played G captures an f5 but
for those of you who were able to play a
better move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy it show the correct
move is g5 and it's a very complicated
move because you're playing against
capablanca who is 8 in 8 and you're
you're you know you have a better
position but one little slip and you
know you it you could just be one more
in a row you could be a 9 in 9 so to say
but the g5 is deadly because here kappa
blanka would have 2 2 options Queen
captures or Queen to e6 so let's explore
the obvious one first if Queen captures
on g5 then of course rook H to g1
attacks the Queen and connects the rook
is now attacking the g7 square and also
the bishop here and now after you move
the Queen let's say Queen h6 now comes
Luke captures with check and now if you
go King to h8 then all sorts of nasty
discoveries are possible white can just
win the Queen and the game so you have
to go King to f8 or you can just capture
the rook with the Queen but then again
you're down Queen so here rook captures
and d7 the thread is Bishop to g7 check
winning the Queen and after the Queen
moves let's say queen h5 now you go
Bishop to g7 you know either way King
has to go to g8 and now just look to g1
and we have this beautiful position
where black has no no good move any move
you make doesn't really make sense and
the white can just either grab this
point I can grab this pawn be up
material if you play any move that puts
your piece on a dark square white can
just make any sort of discovery and win
that piece so white is completely
winning in this position so obviously
after g5 you cannot capture the pawn you
have to go Queen to e6 but now now it's
where it becomes complicated most likely
rosenthal saw that the g5 Queen captures
doesn't work but here if he found move
the movie 4 then I'm sure he would have
gone for g5 but it's a really it's not
complicated once you once you know it's
there but if you don't you know you're
playing capablanca you're not gonna go
for this but after F captures FK
D captures and Queen captures we have
Queen captures Bishop captures now you
see the point and it's not all that
difficult to calculate this it's a few
captures and now you see that white is
left with a powerful Bishop repair and
it doesn't really matter what black
plays any move that black plays let's
say you try to activate the knight h6 is
coming and now you see the problem the
bishop pair is too strong
you can either capture which doesn't
make all our you know really a lot of
sense or you can go G 6 and now White's
idea is Bishop captures and G 6 where
you if you capture it in just H 7 wins
the game king of seven now you bring a
knight into the game you're just up
material so black would have to give up
the exchange and now well there's really
not much to do against rook to h7 so
this is again completely winning for
white and on the other hand after Bishop
captures you could also go for rook
captures rook first and then after rook
captures only then capture the bishop
but again rook to e7 just attacks the
two pieces and there's no defense
against h7 check the King has to go away
and then h8 brings another Queen into
the game again completely winning like
say King f8 you just capture a piece and
whatever you do h 7h 8 is coming so
unfortunately for Rosenthal after couple
on because f5 he didn't find g5 but you
know that's I mean it's just a lack of
the strong or fortune favors the strong
as they say here he played the G
captures on f5 but it's not a blunder or
anything white still remains with a
better position but here kappa blanka
played d4 now attacking the pinned pawn
as the Queen from h8 connects with the
King and c1 and also the rook is
attacking the e3 pawn and here Jacob
called Rosenthal played King Tubby one
and it was in this position and move 31
that Jake caught Rosenthal and josé raúl
capablanca agreed to a draw now
unfortunately I don't have the
information and who offered the draw but
it is a rule in chess that you offer a
draw after you've made your move now
player players often agree to draws
without you know following this rule but
I don't know if I had to guess I mean
it's hard to guess either
Rosenthal was a very
excited that he has a better position
against Capablanca and he was just
hoping not to lose the game as everyone
else in the tournament so far lost a
couple Lanka so maybe he played King b1
offered the drawing cup of monk was like
yeah I'll take that draw or kappa blanka
knew that he was losing and he offered
the draw to Rosenthal and Rosenthal just
accepted it as you know it's a very very
nice draw against such a strong player
but even after King to be won
Rosenthal could've just kept playing
because there's no good way for black to
win this game I mean of course that
that's easy to say when you play against
kappa blanka there's always way stand to
lose the game but here even if you just
trade down let's say rook captures on e3
rook captures Queen captures on d3 Queen
captures and D captures now yes Blanca
does have a very strong passed pawn
the problem is rook to g1 there's no
good way to defend the g7 point White's
the bishop pair once again proves too
strong here let's say King f8 Bishop
captures on g7 check King f7 or not king
a king to f7 Bishop to b3 check and now
you've created a path for your passport
here King te 8 and now f6 the thread is
f7 f8 and here okay you can block at
Knight c3 check King can move king b2
and now 95 blocks the bishops control of
the f7 square but then just Bishop c2
you can go and grab this pawn start
pushing your H pawn black might be able
to hold this especially if Capablanca is
playing but there's there's no way for
whites to lose here so it's very very
strange that white would accept a draw
here maybe ok it's hard to say maybe he
accepted it maybe he offered it and then
kappa blanka accepted it i don't know
maybe if you have a nice theory or maybe
you have an exact like fact what
happened here be sure in the in the
comments below as it is strange but it
is a wonderful game and especially after
this f5 the the complications that arise
after g5 is played it's just it's just
insane
but yeah after this King to be one move
the players agreed to a draw and well
this is the first setback for Capablanca
in this tournament
eight wins in a row then this draw
against Jacob call Rosenthal
but you know still having a great
tournament and an excellent game for
jae-gook or Rosenthal who could have
well if he pushed g5 he this would
probably be Rosenthal's immortal but you
know it just wasn't meant to be yeah
that's it for this game I also have a
special announcement I have a shout out
to make or to a certain johannes for his
birthday so happy birthday Johannes
there we have it this is Johannes his
but his girlfriend sent me this photo
wish you happy birthday so I do hope you
had a great birthday was yesterday and
here if you really zoom in to this photo
there are a lot of books in the
background and one of the books is
titled life is sweet so indeed if you
enjoyed chest this much life certainly
is sweet so I really really hope you
have an excellent birthday and that you
will have an excellent life man so there
you have it and also I do owe you the
story of the couch so if you're
interested it's not a very long story
it's not an exciting story but I bought
the new couch as you can see the one
back there because the old one was
really really just old it's prehistoric
and well I ordered the new one and they
said okay it will arrive in a week and
then I got rid of the old one and I said
okay I mean I can be without a couch for
for a few days and then after that week
passed they didn't even contact me they
haven't notified me or anything
and then the couch just wasn't delivered
and then after I contacted them they
said yeah they were not gonna deliver it
and I was like what's what's the idea
here and they were like yeah we're just
too busy and I okay I was like so when
will you deliver it and they said well
we're gonna deliver it a week from now
and so I said okay I mean there's
there's no way in fighting this I said
or all right I will wait for yet another
week without a couch in my apartment and
then another week passed and they still
haven't delivered it and then they said
it will arrive tomorrow and okay
tomorrow I wasn't at my home I had to
drive my mother to the hospital and the
couch did arrive but the couch is over
100 kilograms and well they only sent
one person to bring it up to my
apartment
and I specifically asked when I bought
them will you
I mean will enough people deliver the
couch and they said yeah sure of course
I mean of course at least two people
will deliver it and then I wasn't at
home only one people only one person
came and then luckily my girlfriend was
home they told her that either she will
help them carry the couch or they will
return the couch to where it came from
and then okay somehow they managed to
bring the house in there I managed to
set it up and everything and it's just
one very hard say it was just a very
unpleasant experience and I will not
name this company that I ordered it from
even though I'd want to so you don't
make the same mistake as me but I'm not
gonna do it as you know I don't know I
just decided not to do it but that's the
story behind the couch and finally it's
here and you know it's it's a very nice
couch I enjoy it Mader enjoys it my
girlfriend enjoys so I'm very happy
about that
but yeah that's the story behind the
couch story if you expected some really
you know spectacular story but you know
to me it was very painful but yeah once
again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Anthony
Cox Michael route Co Rafa Quintero
Godinez Christopher Fernandez and
Anastacio suno's for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
you know with everything that that
follows and yeah thank you I'll see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day